so uh wow now that we're adequate
adequately laughing at absurdities
should we uh yeah let's get into this
story oh gosh
i mean i'm stoked about this is great
news i think oh man okay
i'm hoping i'm hoping that uh so now we
see this this is a story from the hill
fauci totally in favor of reopening
country if done in an inappropriate
done in an appropriate way not in an
interview
no if it's not appropriately he's saying
we can reopen
this is amazing news you know why yes it
is we've seen studies the lockdowns
didn't work
we've seen studies that they may have
made things worse yeah affectionate rate
isn't as bad all right i got one we're
gonna show it we're gonna show a study
from
jp morgan did an assessment of all these
different states and they're writing
fake news about hydroxychloroquine and
stuff it's the weirdest it's the
weirdest thing
but now that fauci has come out they've
lost their
you know golden calf or whatever they've
there's yeah okay that was the only
defense they had was that fauci was
well look fouchy is saying we should
remain locked down so
i mean he's exactly he's the leader
right he was the weather bane yes
yeah yep now uh he's totally in favor
and he actually
he's actually talking about why it's bad
check this out the nation's leading
infectious disease expert anthony fauci
said friday that he's totally in favor
of reopening the country if it's done
appropriately and cautiously
in an interview with cnbc fauci said the
notion the nation can't stay locked down
adding that irreparable damage and
unintended consequences
could ensue if lockdowns are prolonged
including risks to public health
it is for that reason why the guidelines
are being put forth so the states and
the cities can start to re-enter and
reopen he said
there it is yeah glorious glorious
statement thank you dr fauci
thank you finally he says i don't uh i
believe this yes
how she says this i don't want people to
think that any of us feel that staying
locked down for a prolonged period of
time
is the way to go he said adding that the
nation had to do that during the virus
outbreak's peak
i'm gonna challenge that notion uh with
another article in a second
okay he said that uh that in general he
thinks the most most people in the
country are reopening in a prudent way
now is the time depending upon where you
are or what your situation is
to begin seriously looking at reopening
the economy reopening the country
to try and get back to some degree of
normal i'm totally in favor of that if
it's done in a proper way
and appropriate setting fauci said there
you go
good all right let's see if we get this
there we go
great now that he said it i think we're
on track
you've got weird holdout states you know
like new york michigan
new jersey they want to extend
everything yeah three more weeks
no we can't do that or two more weeks
maybe no like two and a half weeks
june 12th yeah june 12th yeah come on
crazy length
why i think they're scared didn't the
state tell her she can't
do that the legis she was uh i i can't
remember the specific details but i
think she was challenged by the
legislature okay
i don't know i don't remember exactly
what happened all right but i know in
wisconsin
he lost and he gave up the governor
there what's his name evers is that
yeah i think so that sounds right so we
got the study right here
many u.s states have seen lower
infection rates after ending lockdowns
that are now destroying millions of
livelihoods worldwide jpmorgan study
claims
there's actually an argument that the
lockdown made things worse
i believe it look you had it definitely
did
because it's not just fighting off the
coronavirus right
in terms of it stalled our economy out
now we're going to have to like
climb an uphill battle to get back into
like they say the nor
get back to normal it's like how is that
even possible millions of people don't
have jobs
they don't have jobs to go back to once
quarantine gets lifted that's the issue
now
there's no there's like it's too late
for those people the small businesses
that close permanently yeah exactly
normal for these people exactly man
that's that's nuts so what are their
options
you know work at walmart yup
great yeah that's what i was saying
before like if you were somebody say
like own your own shop
yeah now what's your choice become a
mid-level manager at
a walmart version yeah like you you if
you if you had uh
you know like a shoe shop yeah like an
urban streetwear or something
they shut you down walmart's still
selling all those clothes now you're out
of business
you couldn't pay your rent you get
evicted whatever happens your employees
are have moved out of the city
so you're like i guess i'll go to
walmart and manage their shoe aisle well
i mean
didn't you uh didn't you say dominos was
paying like six figures for managing
taco bell
taco bell that's crazy so i'm sure
the jobs are out there yeah yeah before
the lockdown the economy was so good
taco bell was paying managers 100k a
year that's so good
wow that's really good money did you
manage a taco bell seriously so these
are people without degrees
yeah i mean in many circumstances you
know that's good these are even some
people who just
you know got a job at taco bell out of
high school worked there for a couple
years and then got promoted
and now they're like well we want we
want to hire managers so we got to be
competitive
boom economy was great not so much now
but the big the big corporations have
all done really really well
so they're really really well didn't
they make like over 400 mil or something
400 the big the big box stores maybe
more is a billion or a million i
don't remember billionaires saw like a
massive wealth increase
yeah yeah it's so obvious dude it's
obvious
it's so obvious you know it's funny
that's a good advantage there's there's
like a uh
among the like libertarian conspiracy
theorist kind of circles okay
there's this idea actually it's not fair
to say that but this is where i've heard
it from
okay like anarcho-communist i'm sorry no
that was wrong sorry what
and narco capitalist immediately my my
ancap fans friends are like how dare you
oh gosh i'm gonna get hate hate mail
from no but um they talk about how
the elites predict
and well it depends on who you ask but
some people have told me that the elites
orchestrate economic collapse so what
happens is
the market will go really really well
okay and then
they'll you know like sell really high
tank the economy on purpose
and then buy everything back up at
really low prices and then when the
economy recovers
they now have a larger percentage of
everything resources right
yep so i wouldn't you know personally go
so far say they orchestrate it
okay but insider trading is real it's a
crime it exists
people don't know didn't we see those
like senators do that didn't they have
like
a meeting and then the very next day
sold off millions of stock
so there's a couple that happened i
don't know yeah there's a couple people
one of them
it sounds fishy yeah but then uh the uh
what's her name lafleur is her name
kelly loffler
as from my understanding now hers
doesn't seem fishy okay because hers is
like a blind trust
and she had nothing to do with whether
they bought her soul yeah she's not
planning on stepping down
so i don't think she's it's the other
guy what's his name like burr or
whatever
yeah oh he was super fishy yeah he seems
weird
okay but dude they do it look look why
is nancy pelosi worth millions of
dollars gosh she scares me
[Laughter]
there's regular joey adam being like
she's a scary woman she scares me man
why does she scare you because she's got
this look on her face
that she doesn't care what you're saying
she's going to continue saying what she
believes
and she believes it 100 but doesn't
trump that even if it's wrong
but that describes trump too man
like yeah yeah i mean i wouldn't want to
cross trump either but you know
for that matter you know the differences
though i don't know why i'm not afraid
of trump
this is one of the weirdest things about
some current state of politics
something about pelosi man something
about her yeah she'd poison my food i
think
so her daughter said her daughter used
this as a selling point for her mom
she's like she'd cut your head off and
you wouldn't even know it and i was like
yes supposed to be good or right so
she'd wait till i was sleeping
exactly yeah trump would come
trump would like walk and be like adam
i've had enough and
throw you the sword let's go yeah it's a
fair fight yeah exactly
and then
we watched the family guy the other day
where peter fought donald trump that was
kind of funny oh yeah
and that's funny no but there's a weird
thing about how like
trump flaunts his wealth he loves his
wealth yeah
and republicans love his wealth the
conservatives they're like good for him
you know
yeah and the democrats like hide from
and apologize for it
like for their wealth for their for
their for like
it's the weirdest thing i'm sorry i'm
privileged is that what you mean
that kind of thing yeah like you know if
people find out they like a fancy dinner
they're like oh no like what do i do
and trump specifically is like i'm
having a fancy dinner
trump boom here's an example here's the
example
elizabeth warren has you know she gets
off a private jet
a tiny one yeah and she immediately
ducks behind somebody yeah
wait wait wait wait trump pulls the
jumbo jet up behind him while he's
speaking
you know that's the person who owns it
amazing
i don't want to say the word but owning
up to your ass you know it's like saying
it's like trump saying yeah i'm rich and
i know it and yeah warren saying oh no
they found out
oh no it's weird it's weird i know i'm
rich now yeah just silently taking
millionaires out of his conversation
just the billionaires the billionaires
but so so think about this right
in terms of how they've advocated for or
against lockdown you've got trump saying
we'd reopen
okay apparently now there's like a quote
i i need to fact check this one but you
know trump said something like we'll
never do this again
you know this can't happen and then you
look at the what the democrats have for
he's talking about locking down you mean
right shutting down the economies yeah
all right it's not it's not so much
about
it it's hard to describe like when i say
the democrats
i'm typically typically typically
referring to the establishment
vote blue no matter who kind of people
including the politicians their media
allies
it's like that cluster of weird faction
or whatever their attitudes toward
lockdown have been completely
asynchronous with the science the
studies the the economy
and it's just the weirdest
i i can't i can't imagine regular people
trust them
i'm sure weird resistance types who
don't pay attention do yeah
but you know in in line with what we're
just saying about how like the democrats
will pretend
and trump will own it i think that's one
reason why
people they they trust trump even though
he says outrageous
things fairly often yeah they don't
trust the media and then the media
starts playing this game where every day
they end up proving trump right the
media is full of you know full of it
yeah and then what happens is you end up
with trump
and they just people would rather
believe the president
you know it's it's crazy i mean there
was a study what a couple weeks ago that
the general approval rate for the
president was high from the press
and that doesn't surprise me there was a
cbs poll that said trump was more
trustworthy by like two points
here's the funny thing like cnn
immediately rushes out to do a poll on
this
okay and then there paul comes out and
says trump is at 36 and cnn is at 55 or
whatever
okay guys like okay they just did the
poll in their own office
yeah they're like quick we need some
numbers quick everyone who works here
and has we it's paid by us do this poll
for us we need your feedback
we also saw this this story um what
what's what's the date on this one i
will not support may 12th fought you
tells congress there's no guarantee that
the vaccine is actually going to be
effective
oh wow right right but this is a good
example of what i'm talking about
they're they're out of sync with what's
actually going on yeah and i bring this
up because i wonder now if we're
actually going to reopen even though
fauci said it
so i'm all excited fauci's like we
should reopen i'm like yes but guess
what
fauci said a week ago 10 days ago yeah
over a week ago
over 10 days ago there's no guarantee
it's effective what does los
angeles say what does new jersey say
yeah because it's a virus we've known
that no no they said we need we can't
reopen
until we have a vaccine that's
ridiculous are you listening to fouchy
yeah they're not right that's the
weirdest thing
man that's these that's sad man because
i mean we know we've we've talked about
this
right you can't get a vaccine for
viruses because they'll just mutate
no you can vaccine viruses you can't
cure viruses okay oh i see all right
so you give yourself the immunity by you
know giving you little bits of the
you know weakened virus or whatever your
body destroys it makes the antibodies
and
okay i think that's how it works right
yes yeah i'm i'm not
i am not in fact a fancy doctor or any
kind well we treat you like our fancy
doctor yeah but the
uh vaccination is it putting a little
bit of a weakened strain of whatever it
is into your body so that your your
cells develop an immune response to
whatever it is right and this is why the
flu vaccine fails half the time yeah
that's because it's developed in
conjunction with
australia we never even get their their
strain of the flu
which tends to backfire because it's
like well we were working because that's
a different strain
exactly so we got different ones in the
u.s i'm annoyed with fouchy
why are you absolutely why there have
been a lot of conspiracy theorists and
there's been a lot of anger towards him
i'm not saying the same thing
there have been conspiracy people who
think you know a bunch of stuff about
him then there's angry people people who
are met at him
you know because of his wishy-washiness
and that's that's what i think is on
point
he says what in march don't wear a mask
you know you're actually you're actually
you know tricking yourself into thinking
you're gonna be safe blah blah
and then what happens a month later if
you don't wear a mask you get arrested
yeah so fauci has been she watching
people get arrested and some people get
handed masks by the craps
and that's that's a whole other subject
too here's here's what i think
it really does feel like fauci is just
doing whatever he thinks is safe
that's why i'm annoyed yeah okay when
these studies came out
saying the vaccines might not be
effective a week later he goes well they
might not be effective it's like did you
just read the story it came out a week
ago
yeah then weren't you supposed to be the
leading expert on this
he's supposed to be the one setting the
opinions on this yeah but what it really
does feel like is that he's waiting
until the the media says something that
seems safe
and then he like he's like he waits
until
the the public has saturated what they
said and it's like oh okay
yeah it is safe yep all right i'll say
it exactly so now that you're seeing a
bunch of studies pop up saying lock down
prolonged block time is making things
worse
we've got two studies we got the study
from jp morgan there was another study
saying that 66
of people who were getting infected were
the ones staying home
and it made it's obvious for one we're
learning about vitamin d yeah
but people so the easy way i explain to
people is listen
if you go out you're less likely to come
in contact
with the same you know surfaces as
somebody locked in a house because in
the house
everyone's in a crammed tight space yeah
everyone's in the kitchen open in the
fridge
going to the bathroom right you know
like anything like that yeah so what
ends up happening is
the people who go out rarely get sick
but if
one of them does get sick and they go
home then so if there's four people at
home and one person working
the one person might get sick they come
back home and now there's four at home
people sick
so the people who are staying home are
more likely to get sick because they're
in close proximity
so uh and then the people who live by
themselves for instance
so ultimately what the study said was
more exposure to sunlight
less likely to come in contact with
surfaces even outside
see this is exactly what those doctors
in california were talking about the the
video that kept getting deleted
that's all they were talking about we
need to be out there to expose ourselves
to
not not just coronavirus but all viruses
that we hit up
bacteria that we hit up because our
immune system naturally is fighting it
at all times
when you're locked in like that's
another thing into this study when
you're locked in your immune system just
slowly gets worse and worse and worse
because you're not
constantly fighting new stuff and
building up and about the natural
antibodies to kill them
and with that being said i just want to
do a quick reminder to the youtube
person who's got their fingers shaking
over the band button like just just
eager to dr fauci says it's time to
reopen
okay all right so i defer to the doctor
who said that he is absolutely in favor
of opening up
so you can move your finger away from
the band but yeah yeah yeah look at this
article yeah
it's dr fauci this article is huge
now she says so mm-hmm that's totally in
favor
check it out but that other article
though it i think spark go
bring up the other one the one about the
vaccine yeah this is this is
way more important no guarantee that the
vaccine is actually going to be
effective
did you hear that california yeah don't
stay locked down
lock down until there's a vaccine that
fauci is saying
isn't what might not even be affected
why are you saying california we're in
jersey and and governor murphy
yeah he said that they hadn't okay did
you hear that new jersey
what else what other states we got yeah
michigan new york i don't know
all those blue states right so so let me
let me tell you guys something
this right now is just speculative we
did we went down to the atlas gym
he did say there's no guarantee
right you know it's a little loose let
me tell you how how freaky things can be
oh tell me this story
i actually know the story but tell them
well there's a little bit more you don't
know about oh
we were saving it for the show we went
down to adolescent we're very very
very very close to here this is the gym
that's made national headlines because
the two owners refused to stay closed
they put up a bunch of social distancing
guidelines people were coming in they
were like i think that
were they doing temperature checks on
people i don't know i don't know if they
were doing that yeah they were being
very careful though very careful yeah
so the cops came told them they were in
violation but then said don't worry
about it like have a nice day
then came back and issued a citation
started issuing citations to people who
were going in
and then arrested one guy briefly
because he didn't identify himself
in the middle of the night apparently
something happened where these guys the
owners show up
and they see health notice like notice
of embargo from the health department
and then they find that the bathrooms
had been flooded from the toilets
so i'm assuming it's sewage yeah it
doesn't necessarily mean it's like raw
nasty it's just you know
whatever gross well it could be more
than water and
they said they found paper towels jammed
in the pipes but they don't have paper
towels in their bathrooms
why would they yeah like you know it's
it's i guess you could have those like
those like
brown napkin things yeah because they
don't have them right so when we went
there
there's uh the building it's like if
this was an overhead view here's the
building
here's the entrance and then there's
this road that goes like this around the
back and there's a cemetery behind it so
there's no way
to get to there unless you hop the fence
in the cemetery okay and this woman told
us
this is just what i heard from a woman
so it couldn't maybe it's fake news i
don't know
she said the other day before the
flooding happened a woman had claimed to
have seen
ducks in a drain or something and then
and then like no one paid attention
everyone ignored her okay but then the
cops shut down the road that went behind
the building
and then the next day it was flooded and
the drain behind the building had the
drain cap removed
and apparently that's where they found
paper towels that could just be
you know hear say she could have been
one woman who heard you know gave a
telephone so i'm not saying it's true
i'm saying very very
much the opposite this is just a story
we were told from out in front of the
building right you're talking about like
animals ducks yes birds yeah birds oh
she just saw some ducks
yeah in a drain that needed to be in the
drain right oh okay
so so then so then after that the cops
blocked the road off
this was we were told how convenient it
was well hold
right and while you're there shove some
uh i have some toilet paper i have no
confirmation the cops ever shut the road
down
right no confirmation there was ever
paper towels found it was reported on
the pratt on the news the two guys said
this happened
i don't know for all i know maybe the
two guys went in and flooded the toilets
and then came back in the morning and
said oh no look our toad's been flooded
yeah the point is the government did it
this is what people think and what
they're saying yeah
so what i said was all all that matters
is
you said the police at the road down
right okay and then paper towels were
jammed in the drain
and the drain cap is suddenly missing
yeah so who knows what that means
yeah people will speculate for sure and
i understand the speculation will lean
towards
it with sabotage there's something else
we noticed
when we were leaving there was a white
nationalist sticker
on a flag on one of the light poles yep
it's like someone took
uh i don't know what it's called but
it's like a the paper with like the glue
and you like
yeah a
and it said something about like you
being a western man and resistance which
way
western man yeah which is a white
nationalist thing right now but then
there was a sticker that said something
like
you let in immigrants and like you see
what happens or whatever or something
like that oh my goodness
look it's crazier somebody handed one of
the owners a megaphone to use
okay and it had white nationalist
stickers on it and so then people took
photos and started checking so they
trapped them
yep well that's a set up if i ever heard
of one yup holy moly and apparently
like some dude showed up screaming nazis
animal and she's like why are you
calling us that
yeah no answer think about how easy it
is to totally discredit anybody
yeah handing my microphone here use this
and then the press takes photos and
they're like look at that sticker
wasn't there a don't tread on me flag
flag but that's a revolution that's an
american revolution flag so
but of course of course they try to
claim the gadsden flag as like white
nationalist which is it
it's not even cool no i thought it was
more libertarian isn't it it's it's
it's a flag of the american revolution
it's historical yeah yeah it's the snake
don't try it on me
yeah and then you have the awesome meme
ones my favorite i love them they're out
there
so you've seen no step on snack yeah my
favorite and i've seen the the base one
too
don't yeah don't that's like a lie the
squiggly line says don't
my favorite is uh the one that someone
sent of you
don't really don't tread on tim oh and
it's got a little beanie on the on the
snake
it's great it's great i'll find it and
post it later oh my favorite
it's so good my favorite is the one that
says don't cough on me and the snake is
wearing a little bag
i like that favorite if only if only
they they could have seen
in the future what we would do with
their navy flag
they had no idea do you know what let me
let me know how many memes let me ask
you a question man
please it's really it's really easy to
say don't try to me and be libertarian
when the country is tiny the population
is in a few million
and everyone lives a mile from each
other i understand there was there were
still cities and towns and they were
closed
but it was it was a lot easier when it
was just 13 colonies
yep well even then you know it's really
funny when i think back but
i think back to the colonies i'm like
it's funny that they considered all of
this territory
the colony when like it's one city on
the water
with you know like a few thousand people
yeah basically like they're like the
whole area
but that's a good point something's
gonna happen and i think it's gonna
happen no matter what we want because of
uh uh
because of population growth okay like
how do you
you know it's it's it look i wanna wake
up at six in the morning and go skate
right
yeah i can't it's too noisy neighbors
get mad so i can't do that
the police will make an ordinance saying
you disrupt too many people therefore
you can't do it
okay so i can't say in that regard don't
tread on me can i
like the government's come and tell me i
can't ride my board i'm not even doing
anything nobody that's not fair don't
tread on me but have some general
respect for your neighbors
is that basically yeah i guess i see
what you're saying though but so so so
look at this way like in limits
in our house right now we can bang on
the drums a lot we want in new york you
can't do that
because everybody's crowned on top of
each other yeah a bunch of shoe boxes
yeah stacked on each other now that
being said new york is collapsing
and everyone's fleeing the city so maybe
yeah the new yorkers are going nuts i've
seen some crazy videos of what's going
on new york people are straight up some
of those
they're straight up banging on the
corner dude what do you mean like
oh that's right right naked wait what do
you mean and banging on the corner
that's that's all i can say but
that's happening like what yeah banging
the drone no no you've just yeah
you've seen the photo the drum quote
unquote drums
you've seen the video of them like
jumping on top of suvs yeah and
everyone's dancing and yelling
going on they're listening so here's the
question i was having right
we can see that there's a tendency to
where like as humans get crammed closer
and closer together
you know can you reasonably demand
certain rights when everyone's living on
top of each other
like obviously base writes yes but i can
play music here and be noisy
can't do it in new york well even just
uh we'll go with the
owning a gun like you can't have a gun
in new york city
is that because people live too close to
each other or because
i mean i don't know i i know that
there's people in new york
like a guy for example i was riding the
subway
sat down i was wearing some brand new
sneakers
i saw a guy look at me walk over walk
past me
step right on my shoes and i was just
like hey man
what like what was that about and he
looked at me and said
he like glanced down he had a razor
blade in his hand he said i'll
cut you say something again i was like
wow and i just i just stood up and like
walked off
but they're charged they're the people
in not everybody in new york but
there's some there's people that are
have aggression issues like i don't know
where he was at i don't know what he was
doing
i didn't even know like what i did to
provoke him i had brand new shoes on
maybe that pissed him off
some people just wanted people in new
york yes but imagine if he had a gun
instead of a razor blade
you know he could have just been like
boom and ran off the stuff
i mean he could have cut my throat i i
don't know do you see the video of those
dudes there's like an asian woman at a
bus stop okay
and these three kids walk up and they're
all laughing and the kid drop kicks her
in the face
it was actually a crane kick called a
drop kick it was a crane kick
no that's not a mess that's so messy
accurately yeah
or do you see the the the was it called
the knockout game they do oh my gosh
we talked about that didn't we maybe
yeah we're going to take the feed out
from underneath
no no no the skull skull cracks
challenges
the knockout game is they run full speed
and hit you as hard as they just punch
someone right in the head
randomly as hard as you can so messed up
what's wrong with people i mean we're
kind of we're kind of steering
you know but i'm talking about new york
like
this is you know it's a different
specifically new york true but i mean
you could do that anywhere
you know we're talking about rules in a
city of people compounding each other
living all together and people can knock
someone out anywhere you're at i'm
talking about
rules versus except if you if if you had
a very very tiny colony
and you had you know the population
density was like 10 people per square
mile so everyone knew each other
not only and not right and so if some
kid was like
i'm gonna go knock out mr johnson he
wouldn't do it
so now you're getting bigger and bigger
cities humans can't know each other that
much they're living on top of each other
but not only that there weren't that
many people to actually look if you had
a murderer back then
it's like they go on the prowl and after
one night find one person whereas in new
york these people walk into a building
and there's 500 people running around
yeah they can go nuts so it's like it's
it's this is interesting because i think
uh
joe kind of mentioned this joe rogan
when i was on the show about
is i think you mentioned this is it a
natural tendency of civilizations that
when they're so old they've been around
for so long they just drift towards
authoritarianism
okay like china for example china for
example but also their population
density
like wuhan is a town of what like 10
million oh gosh that's no that's
a lot of new york city yeah and that's
not even their big we've never even
heard of that exactly
we never even heard of wuhan i didn't i
i can honestly say i've never heard of
wuhan
before this this year do you imagine if
someone's like i've never heard of new
york city where's that
you'd be like are you kidding me come on
come on it's not even one of the like
what is tokyo like 30 million people oh
wow yeah is it really it's so big it's
huge i had no idea
it's the same and we we think like new
york is this big massive
city and it is yeah but to us right
and so you look at how china operates
they welded people's doors shut
that's nuts is that maybe because
there's just too many people now
and then it's also like it's it's i
think it's a product of democracy
and this is one of the problems with
democracy versus a republic for instance
if you have two people and they cross
paths and they get into an argument you
try to
you know mediate hey hey whoa whoa if
you have two people and one person
then you have two witnesses against the
one person and guess who wins the
argument
the two now you have a big city where
you have millions of people
and you get one person who's sick and
you get millions of people saying lock
them up
and they and so that's that's the that's
the uh
the tyranny of the majority so you end
up with these massive
societies with tens of millions of
people crammed into tiny spaces
and they all react like drastically and
violently
towards any threat to the system whereas
if you had a small town somewhere like
we when we were driving la we mentioned
this the other day
there was a town where they did
literally nothing no social distancing
no masks and the lady just laughed we
don't care yeah we're all preppers we
don't care
who was it that said this that they tend
to get more authoritarian
uh joe is asking that okay i have an
idea so i just looked this up because i
looked up
um wuhan so there's a city in china
called chongqing and i don't know if
either of you guys have ever heard of it
probably not
30.48 million people wow
and that makes me think that you can
only control
that larger population what 1.39 billion
by being complete authoritarians there's
no there's like how are you supposed to
do that how do you give that many people
freedom
i don't even know if it would work so
that's just my two cents one person
wants to play right one person wants to
play the drums
and you go bro there's a thousand people
complaining about the drums
yeah they voted you out oh you can't
play the drums now yep and we're gonna
come and fix it for you that's that's
the importance of a bill of rights
yeah like if there was a if there was
like an amendment like
we you know we here by the people
guarantee the right to play drums
then you'd be like i don't care how many
people get mad constitution says i can
play drums all i can think about right
now is this whole social
justice thing it feels like the
beginning because
there's a few people that are screaming
for social justice
and then you know enough people say i
guess
that's something we need to make laws
about and then they make laws and ruin
it for everybody and
kind of like shut it down and then
slowly and slowly we turn into this
authoritarian world
where you're not allowed to do anything
and the government welds your door shut
if there's a pandemic yeah you know
china definitely
but one of the weirdest things that's
happening with social justice stuff is
they're not even arguing the laws
anymore they're just like change the
definition of the word
yeah that's for real to fit the law
that's already in place exactly
so if woman doesn't mean biological
female then the law doesn't mean
biological female
it's it's it's a it's an end run around
how the laws have been formed really
sneaky
yeah i mean really creepy when you look
at it that way it's like
all laws are null and void then because
we can just
change the definition of whatever we
want to to make it not amendment bro
man it's like the the language is
you've got uh one thing the left always
brings about the second amendment brings
up about the second
amendment is that it says a
well-regulated militia
and it's like do you know what any of
those words mean
yeah because there's a bunch of
arguments i've heard one of the
arguments i've heard is that regulated
didn't mean controlled by the government
it meant
armed like regulars
i don't think this is true though but
i'm just saying like to interpret the
word in a different way
to us regulation is like when the
government comes in and says we got all
these checked boxes and now you're
operating properly
you've been you know you're under
regulation you're not allowed to do this
or we'll come in and find you
right but then you can look back and see
and and argue that
back then regulated meant you were
equipped with the best weapons and like
you know the best military gear and
stuff like that so you were up to up to
date
yeah right trained yeah but i don't i
don't think that's true either it's just
something i've heard the point is
people will bring up what they really
meant right
and then the left will argue semantics
so even though
it's clear as of right now what the
second amendment says the right of the
people to keep and bear arms shall not
be infringed
why would we even argue the language
that actually family i made a really
funny joke about it
there uh it was a cutaway gag okay where
they mentioned
um you know the founding fathers were
clear whatever and then it shows a
cutaway
and then they're like are you sure the
language is clear enough on the second
amendment and it's like yeah
what can't you understand everyone can
have a pair of bare arms and then
there's there's bear arms
on the wall he's like you can keep and
keep your arms yeah
yeah that's right it's perfectly clear
yeah i have seen that actually yeah yeah
it's funny
and so as language changes the
amendments you know
will mean something different yeah like
eventually you'll end up with someone
arguing in fringe what does that really
mean and then it'll be a court case and
they'll say infringe actually means and
they'll
they'll say it doesn't mean the
government can't make laws about it it
means there must be due process
so it's all about the arguments right
yeah the founding fathers didn't mean
the government couldn't do it
they meant that it had to be due process
or just changed the word of fringe
or infringed completely to mean
something else yeah
language yup infringed like inflammable
means it can be fringed upon
yeah exactly i love how there's like
archaic words that don't make sense
anymore like
gruntled grunted disgruntled grunting
gruntled means satisfied
that is a good word i've never actually
used or heard before discord told yes
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you